[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur TV
78 actualités info pratiques idée de
sortie pour bien démarrer la soirée dans
les Yvelines voici le programme de ce
mardi 6 juin
les assises de la cybersécurité se
déroulaient ce matin à la Ferme du Manet
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux cette journée
organisée par l'opérateur sen et
Yvelines numérique avait pour objectif
de sensibiliser les acteurs publics à la
menace cyber plusieurs collectivités
hôpitaux notamment dans les Yvelines ont
été dernièrement victimes de pirates
informatiques parmi les intervenants de
ces assises Stéphane blanc président
fondateur de l'entreprise anté-méta qui
est notre invité les U13 féminines de
Trappes sur le toit de France elles sont
revenues hier de Bastia avec le titre de
la madewi Slig le plus grand tournoi de
football amateurs de France les
Yvelinois se sont imposés en finale face
à l'Olympique de Marseille au thème au
terme d'une séance de tir au but retour
sur cette grosse performance avec le
coach Rodriguez la capitaine Lina à midi
et la gardienne Hakima hirsdalen héroïne
de la finale
enfin le nouveau domaine et le nouveau
bassin surtout du domaine national de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye était inauguré
après deux ans de travaux ce dimanche le
grand public était présent pour
découvrir cet élément décoratif dessiné
par le jardinier du roi André Lenôtre
autour de 1680 et avec nous autour de la
table des invités je le disais dans les
titres il y a Stéphane blanc bonsoir
bonsoir président fondateur dans tes
méta entreprise basée à aguyancourt vous
êtes spécialisé dans la cybersécurité
vous accompagnez elle est TPE PME mais
aussi des grands groupes dans les
services numériques vous avez quoi animé
ce matin une conférence lors des Assises
de la cybersécurité qui se déroulait à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux l'idée c'était de
faire un bilan sur les cyber menaces en
France avec un zoom plus particulier sur
les Hauts-de-Seine et les Yvelines
commencer de rouler cette matinée très
bien 150 personnes qui étaient présents
c'est quand même un bel événement
aujourd'hui et puis voilà trois
personnes effectivement sur le plateau
le maire de Huy bien évidemment avec les
sujets l'une des communes victimes de
cyberattaque très très dernièrement tout
à fait effectivement
la structure qui aide aussi à ces
communes et les collectivités locales
les collectivités territoriales qui
tournent autour de l'État
cybermelleveillance.gouv voilà qui était
présent et puis moi-même voilà et la
thématique était bien évidemment assez
large
puisque leur intégralité de la des
enjeux de la cybercriminalité autour des
communes à des hôpitaux et des
collectivités locales et territoriales
on reviendra plus longuement sur ces
assis sur la thématique aussi de la
cybersécurité tout à l'heure dans cette
édition en compagnie notamment de
Nicolas dandry bonsoir de la rédaction
de TV 78 qui nous ferait aussi un retour
sur cette journée à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il est également
invité Rodrigue mbezi bonsoir coach et
même coach heureux on peut le dire des
U13 féminines de l'Étoile Sportive de
Trappes je le disais vous êtes revenus
tout fraîchement de la Corse de Bastia
vous avez disputé la première édition de
la madewi Slig version féminine c'était
le premier tournoi féminin de cette made
et whisling vous l'avez remporté en
finale
grâce à une victoire face à l'Olympique
de Marseille bravo déjà juste pour
présenter la MA des whisling on parle
ici du plus grand tournoi de football
amateur en France c'est bien ça tout à
fait Grégory donc c'est un tournoi qui
se déroule en deux étapes donc il y a la
première étape qui s'appelle la madei
Cup donc c'est des tournois qui sont
régionalisés et ensuite chaque finaliste
pas vainqueur mais chaque finaliste se
qualifie pour pouvoir participer à la
Maddie whisling donc nous on a eu la
chance d'attraper notre ticket avec nos
amis de Rueil-Malmaison et puis la suite
de l'histoire je vous laisse la raconter
on va en parler tout à l'heure mais une
histoire magnifique donc l'ouest
francilien très bien représenté combien
d'équipes sur le tableau féminin il y
avait au final sur la finale donc il y a
eu un petit souci donc il y avait 8
équipes de prévues donc de non pas
réussi à se déplacer donc la formule a
été bah refaite donc c'est à dire qu'on
a une première phase on a affronté tous
nos adversaires donc on fait match nul
contre le Malmaison match nul contre
Marseille et puis on a deux deux
victoires contre les locaux et on
reviendra tout à l'heure sur sur ce
parcours notamment la finale avec la qui
sera présente la capitaine également de
l'équipe la gardienne qui a arrêté deux
penalty en finale juste pour préciser un
peu les choses on fait un petit teasing
moi qui suis gardien de but bien sûr
mettre en avant la performance de la
gardienne on en reviendra on y reviendra
tout à l'heure dans cette émission et
avec nous aussi Céline Charles bonsoir
de la rédaction de TV 78 avec vous à
suivre les informations du jour retour
également dans le 7 8 sur l'édition en
2023 de tracteur blues qui a animé
vendredi et dimanche dernier les
communes de breuilboire Aubert et mes
dents mais avant regardons les
prévisions météo de demain
et il va faire encore chaud demain dans
les Yvelines grand soleil dans la
matinée avec des températures proches
des 20 degrés 17 degrés annoncés par
exemple du côté de Rambouillet elle
l'après-midi le ciel devrait se voiler
le thermomètre lui flirtera autour des
30 degrés 27 degrés sont annoncés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan 28
degrés à Rambouillet et demain ce sera
la saint Gilbert on fait le point tout
de suite sur l'actualité du jour dans
les Yvelines
et on commence les actualités Céline
avec une rencontre entre collégien Yves
Linois et le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et oui rencontre au sommet
pour ses élèves Yves Linois depuis le
mois de janvier une dizaine de
collégiens de l'établissement Charles
Péguy au chênes régulièrement des
personnalités politiques après Yaël
Braun Pivet ou Gérard Larcher les jeunes
ont pu discuter ce matin avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale pas
peine Diagne au sein de son ministère à
Paris l'occasion d'échanger autour de
ses fonctions politiques et des valeurs
républicaines les collégiens ont même pu
accéder au bureau du ministre on écoute
les réactions des élèves au micro de
Julien Leroy j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses il s'occupe pas que du scolaire
parce que aussi du périscolaire de
vacances et tout ce qui va avec pour les
enfants la visite aussi elle était
c'était bien justement la bibliothèque
elle est vraiment très belle
et aussi du coup il y a toute le mur de
toutes les ministres de l'éducation et
du de l'éducation nationale
mais direction à présent Flins-sur-Seine
où la production des Renault Zoé est à
l'arrêt oui cependant trois semaines la
raison des difficultés
d'approvisionnement de composants
électroniques ou de semi-conducteur
c'est l'annonce faite par le groupe
Renault et les syndicats selon un tract
de force ouvrières citées par nos
confrères de France Bleu ce sont les
trois semaines de juin ainsi que les
trois et quatre juillet qui sont
concernés toujours le syndicat 355
employés vont être placés au chômage en
activité partielle de longue durée 33 on
peut le présenter comme notre chiffre du
jour 33 artisans yvelinois ont été mis à
l'honneur lors de la première édition du
label artisan du tourisme Grégory et
c'est un label créé par la Chambre des
Métiers et de l'Artisanat
d'Île-de-France Yvelines en partenariat
avec le département alors comme vous
l'avez dit 33 artisans se sont vus
remettre le label hier lundi 5 juin au
domaine de Madame Élisabeth à Versailles
parmi on retrouve des artisans d'art
comme des ébénistes des couteliers des
luthiers mais aussi des représentants
des métiers de bouche comme des
brasseurs des fromagers ou encore des
chocolatiers alors ce label est donné
selon divers critères innovations
originalité qualité de l'accueil du
client ou encore savoir faire local une
belle récompense qui au-delà de donner
de la visibilité à nos artisans permet
de mettre en valeur la multiplicité des
savoir-faire dans le département et une
information pour les passionnés de rugby
ça va ravir Nicolas dandry qui est avec
nous au Plateau
c'est Grégory le coup d'envoi de la
Coupe du monde de rugby 2023 sera donné
le 8 septembre prochain et comme vous le
savez sûrement la ville de Versailles
accueillera pendant 5 semaines l'équipe
du Pays de Galles les joueurs
s'entraîneront d'ailleurs au stade de
porschefontaine et c'est en vue de cet
événement que les la ville ainsi que le
Rugby Club de Versailles vous invite à
venir admirer le célèbre trophée web
hélice il fera étape le 8 juin prochain
au stade de Porchefontaine et le 19 juin
devant l'hôtel de ville pour rappel il
sera remis au vainqueur de la Coupe du
monde du rugby à 15 et autre information
dans le même thème de club bibulinois
ont été sélectionnés pour être
ramasseurs de balles lors de cette Coupe
du monde le club Rambouillet sport et le
plaisir Rugby Club la sélection s'est
faite à l'issue d'une campagne de
recrutement lancée par le Gyps France
2023 et la Fédération française de rugby
une étape le 10 juin le 18 juin prochain
au stade de Porchefontaine le trophée
webbellis c'est le trophée de la Coupe
du monde voilà que la France va chercher
va se tenter d'aller chercher en vendre
début novembre prochain je suis parti en
tout cas des favoris les Français merci
beaucoup Céline pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes témoin
d'une actualité qui vous fait réagir
n'hésitez pas à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
7 8 news
et on parle à présent de ces assises de
la cyber sécurité qui se déroulait ce
matin la Ferme du Manet à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux une journée
organisée par l'opérateur scène et
Yvelines numérique et qui avait pour
objectif de sensibiliser les acteurs
publics sur les risques cyber on en
parle avec notre invité à Stéphane blanc
qui est directeur fondateur président
fondateur dans tes méta et aussi avec
vous Nicolas Landry de la rédaction de
TV 78 et des assises qui sont tenus dans
un contexte particulier on peut le dire
puisque dernièrement plusieurs
collectivités il y a aussi des hôpitaux
et notamment dans les Yvelines qui ont
été victimes de pirates informatiques un
chiffre Grégory une trentaine d'attaques
alors c'est pas un chiffre officiel
c'est un chiffre de l'association déclic
qui a fait le recensement à partir des
informations récoltées une veille sur la
presse locale voilà les cyberattaques
sont souvent traités par la presse
locale elle a fait une veille donc 30
attaques en Île-de-France depuis 2019
dont 5 dans le département des Yvelines
et ça c'est on parle de la fonction
publique vous avez parlé des
collectivités des hôpitaux c'est la
fonction publique française alors
l'enjeu de cybersécurité par rapport à
la fonction publique et bien c'est un
enjeu de souveraineté puisque quand vous
parlez de fonction publique c'est nos
données ce sont les données personnelles
des habitants ce sont les cantines c'est
son la gestion des des territoires et
donc par exemple trois dates septembre
2022 la mairie des Mureaux a été attaqué
décembre 2022 l'attaque de l'hôpital
André Mignot de Versailles qui a été
totalement paralysé il y a encore des
conséquences en cours actuellement et
puis dernier en date c'était en mai
dernier la mairie de jussiers une
attaque pro russe
voilà la guerre dépasse même les
frontières et va même jusqu'à
l'impression que ça se multiplie se
multiplier alors on va revenir sur une
des attaques à défrayer la chronique un
sel de Houilles avec le maire et on
écoute tout de suite Julien Chambon le
maire de la ville de Houilles
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus concevoir
nos investissements informatiques sans
la couche cyberprotection c'est
indispensable donc ça vous comporter à
la fois des solutions techniques et
technologiques firewall system donc pour
repérer les virus en direct sur les
postes de travail et aussi l'aspect
humain ça veut dire que aujourd'hui on
travaille avec les agents de la
collectivité pour les sensibiliser et
faire en sorte qu'ils soient aussi
partenaire de la sécurité du quotidien
en termes informatique de pas cliquer
sur un lien donc très régulièrement il y
a des pièges qui leur sont envoyés à
travers des mails notamment on voit le
taux de clics et on retravaille avec les
équipes derrière pour dire attention
vous avez pas fait attention à ça
comment est-ce qu'on fait attention à un
email qui a l'air qui a l'air
vraisemblablement authentique mais en
fait qu'il l'est pas et qui est un piège
tout simplement pour capter une donnée
importer un logiciel malveillant dans
votre système informatique votre
téléphone ou votre ordinateur donc il y
a tout ce travail et humain et
technologique qu'il faut faire en même
temps
Stéphane blonde et cyberata qui se
multiplient c'est une réalité ou
finalement peut-être juste une
impression qui a mise en avant un peu
plus par les médias dernièrement est-ce
que on a une multiplication dernièrement
là vous parlez collectivités
territoriale vous mettez pas en face
effectivement les ETI les PME et les
grands groupes non c'est c'est en
croissance bien évidemment la situation
on a en face de nous
des gens dans ces métiers c'est le job
voilà plutôt que de braquer des banques
c'est plus facile aujourd'hui que de
braquer à travers la cybercriminalité
les systèmes d'information de toutes les
entreprises et des collectivités locales
ou territoriales ou les hôpitaux de
l'Europe voilà qui est une cible qui est
unique cible vulnérable bien sûr bien
sûr avec qui rapporte
les données Vous demandez des rançons
voilà le business est monté
c'est c'est ce sont des très belles
entreprises qui ont pignon sur rue qu'on
connaît qui sont sur le Dark voilà vous
pouvez bien évidemment vous faire même
enrôler par eux on vous propose des
logiciels
c'est assez étonnant oui je sais bien
c'est un peu surprenant c'est un peu
surprenant
Nicolas oui effectivement et puis vous
l'avez dit les assises du département ça
sert vraiment à sensibiliser alors
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai parlé des
communes de Houilles de Juziers juger
ces 3000 habitants et des Mureaux où il
y a les Mureaux c'est quand même des
grosses villes mais ça touche aussi les
zones rurales et on va parler notamment
de la ville de mitainville c'est une
toute petite commune dans le
sud-yvelines de 650 habitants et ça y
est la mère de cette commune a pris
conscience que la cybersécurité ça peut
aussi concerner sa commune nous n'étions
pas dans une dans une inquiétude haute
de décibère attaques parce que nous
sommes une toute petite commune et à
tort on a peut-être effectivement
l'impression que
ne craint pas grand chose en tout cas on
a mis les moyens en ce qui concerne
toutes nos sauvegardes avec un avec une
société d'informatique qui vient faire
régulièrement nos maintenance c'est vrai
que la notion de moyen humain et de
budget va aussi se poser voilà donc oui
oui effectivement moi ma présence ici
c'est vraiment de de Me sensibiliser
d'abord et ensuite de pouvoir aller
solliciter les bons acteurs
alors dans cette interview Stéphane
blanc on entend parler de matériel on
entend parler le mot humain aussi c'est
important c'est aussi important en fait
la technologie est aussi importante que
l'humain parce qu'aujourd'hui la plupart
des cyberattaques c'est la cause c'est
l'humain déjà la complexité c'est bien
de recruter et encore plus dans des
collectivités locales territoriales des
hôpitaux nous à la rigueur on est des
industriels c'est notre métier de
recruter des gens d'un niveau et d'une
compétence et puis vous vous rendez
compte que les systèmes se complexifient
donc la nécessité d'avoir plusieurs
compétences est une problématique nous
on cherche bien évidemment à y répondre
à répondre à ces enjeux de compétences
et puis il y a des métiers qui sont pas
intéressants enfin prenez le backup
pour moi est un élément stratégique
c'est vraiment un des points focus dans
tes méta c'est bien de de le secours du
système d'information c'est la
convergence de la sécurité on parle
souvent de cybers on parle rarement de
secours sauf que si vous n'avez pas le
secours si vous n'avez pas le backup
pour plan de reprise d'activité c'est le
dernier rempart c'est le dernier rempart
qui doit être opérationnel pour
redémarrer un système d'information et
ça c'est stratégique et trouver des gens
qui ont envie de faire du backup ça
n'intéresse personne juste pour
vulgariser le backup c'est pourquoi pour
noter les spectateurs notamment le
backup c'est l'action vous avez à leur
bien évidemment individuellement sur vos
PC j'espère en tout cas bien évidemment
mais dans l'entreprise c'est bien de
sauvegarder son système d'information
et puis derrière c'est testé ces
sauvegardes parce que vous pouvez
sauvegarder si vous le testez pas et
puis il faut penser métier vous ne
sauvegardez pas
vous devez sauvegarder dans un concept
métier parce que quand vous devez
restaurer vous devez restaurer un métier
et quel métier vous resterez en premier
et alors ces métiers là et ben les gens
n'aiment pas et alors du coup vous
imaginez j'ai conçu même un mot moi pour
ça j'ai conçu un adjectif maintenant
pour amener les jeunes à aller j'appelle
ça du Sibérie cover la cyber résilience
voilà pour mettre le mot cyber en face
du plus vieux métier du monde de l'Haïti
qui est le backup le plan de reprise
d'activité et vous avez l'impression que
il y a un peu plus de prises en compte
on les on l'entendait dans les dans les
propos de la mère de de ces enjeux
cybersécurité aujourd'hui par exemple on
parle des collectivités elles prennent
plus en compte aujourd'hui ces enjeux je
leur souhaite je leur souhaite c'est
essentiel c'est vital aujourd'hui si
vous avez pas un plan de backup correct
de donc excuse-moi de sauvegarde
j'essaye d'utiliser les mots appropriés
et donc de tester si on regarde à
travers un plan de reprise d'activité
vous ne redémarrez pas parce que de
toute façon quel que soit le budget et
encore une fois je ne je n'oppose pas
sécurité secours vous méprenez pas sur
mes propos mais en revanche je dis une
chose si vous ne testez pas vos
processus de secours vous ne
redémarrerez pas vous ne redémarrerez
pas et l'important c'est de redémarrer
même si vous prenez cinq jours même
s'ils prennent 10 jours pour redémarre
c'est de redémarrer le plus important et
c'est ce qu'on offre aujourd'hui c'est
ce qu'on propose dans un modèle de tiers
de confiance parce que c'est trop ça
devient trop complexe et parce que ça
c'est du 7 24 ça veut dire que quand on
voit par exemple incident qui s'est
déroulé à l'hôpital André Mignot du
généraux concours cet enjeu n'avait pas
encore été pris à sa de valeur on va
dire ce qu'on a vu que ça ça perturbait
et il y a encore aujourd'hui des
conséquences Nicolas le disait la prise
en compte quand même des patients il y a
vraiment eu aussi sur l'offre de soins
un manque après suite à cette
cyberattaque c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on propose aujourd'hui à travers bien
évidemment les différents par les
divines numériques voilà ils viennent
numérique propose de service
aux collectivités locales et aux
hôpitaux bien évidemment alors de
chiffre d'affaires par exemple vous
travaillez plus quand même avec des
entreprises avec du privé que de la
fonction publique aujourd'hui oui c'est
vrai parce que il faut trouver encore
les les marchés qui permettent d'accès
dans ce type de marché et
voilà il vit numérique a su ouvrir à ce
type de marché assez innovant dans cette
démarche c'est pas le cas
malheureusement de tous les marchés
publics aujourd'hui d'être innovant dans
cette démarche là et vous avez une
activité qui ne cesse de croire à
travers je me rappelle d'une émission
que nous avions enregistré en 20 vous
étiez à 90 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires aujourd'hui vous allez nous
annoncer le chiffre de cette année c'est
ça 77 sur 20 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires c'est c'est 300 personnes
bien évidemment c'est tout un tas de
certifications
de santé parce que tout ça ça doit
s'accompagner des bonnes démarches des
bonnes pratiques d'accord pour garantir
ce que l'on produit à nos à nos clients
parce que derrière on s'engage moi je
m'engage sur la restauration c'est un
vrai sujet
donc les bonnes pratiques les
compétences et puis essayer de bien
évidemment on est en Yvelines
mais c'est bien évidemment d'embaucher
des collaborateurs de
la région bien sûr et c'est un élément
essentiel on a des très belles
universités une dernière question est-ce
que vous avez l'impression que les
territoires aujourd'hui sont des cibles
plus importantes on va plus les cibler
par rapport à des entreprises que vous
accompagnez vous davantage
je dirais qu'une entreprise ça va pas
forcément dire
voilà parce que vous imaginez par
rapport au fournisseurs aux clients au
banquier c'est tout de suite finalement
c'est voilà et puis voilà des
obligations je dis pas qu'une entreprise
a pas certaines obligations en fonction
de leur taille mais aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que dans une entreprise ça peut ça
peut potentiellement être tabou voilà
parce que parce que le risque derrière
économique est important alors peut-être
qu'un jour vous fait revenir à propos de
l'assurance qu'est-ce que cyber qui est
un autre qui est un autre sujet enfin
qui est une thématique ici bien
évidemment été essentielle également
pour eux mais
on parle quand même d'enjeux qui sont
extrêmement stratégiques aujourd'hui
alors des fois ça
voilà je pousse le bouchon un peu loin
sur sur cette thématique là mais c'est
volontaire tes volontaire très
rapidement très rapidement c'est juste
pour conclure parce que on dit qu'il y a
énormément de cyberattaque mais il y a
quand même beaucoup de cyberatta qui
sont contrées et qui n'ont pas eu lieu
du coup du fait notamment de
collaborateurs comme chez anthemeta ou
d'autres collaborateurs on pense
notamment sur le territoire arabus
cybersécurité ou d'autres startups même
qui sont spécialisés dans ce domaine là
merci en tout cas Stéphane blanc d'être
venu en parler en plateau je crois c'est
un sujet qui est inquiétait à côté de
vous Rodriguez ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure le moins inquiétude parce qu'on
parle de données personnelles donc c'est
clair que de savoir que qu'on se fait
attaquer comme ça et qu'on peut perdre
nos données est capable dans la nature
je trouve ça super inquiétant donc merci
pour le travail écoutez je vous remercie
c'est sympa merci pour le vôtre aussi
parce que nos jeunes il faut s'en
occuper et c'est bien on félicite je
pense qu'on va tomber d'accord voilà
c'est le plateau des rencontres
et on va parler bien sûr dans un instant
de la grosse performance réalisée par
les féminines de Trappes lors de la
madewi's Ligue merci encore d'avoir été
avec nous Stéphane blanc tout d'abord un
autre sujet jusqu'au 9 juin c'est la
Semaine de la santé sexuelle à cette
occasion le département des Yvelines a
organisé il y a quelques jours une table
ronde pour présenter les actions des
centres de santé sexuelle et parler
aussi éducation Gabriel Gontier il a
rencontré Edwige Pichon elle est
infirmière sexothérapeute et a créé un
compte Instagram spécialisé
[Musique]
à la santé sexuelle mais aussi au
plaisir sexuel qui est tenu donc par
moi-même qui suis infirmière
sexothérapeute l'idée c'est de libérer
la parole autour de la sexualité pour
que ça devienne un sujet comme un autre
et que donc ça devienne moins tabou mon
envie première c'est aussi que les gens
prennent conscience des enjeux de la
sexualité notamment du consentement du
non consentement mais aussi qu'on puisse
un petit peu s'amuser au lit et parce
que l'éducation sexuelle est vraiment
centrée sur la prévention dans les
établissements mais moi j'ai aussi envie
que tout le monde puisse s'épanouir dans
sa sexualité et ça passe aussi par le
plaisir
[Musique]
nous on a envie de de réinvestir la
sexualité qui soit pas une sexualité
crue et sans et sans interaction autour
on parle aussi de connexion émotionnelle
de de liens à son propre corps parce que
la sexualité c'est pas que la sexualité
à deux et l'idée c'est vraiment de
remettre ça dans un contexte
bienveillant consentant enthousiaste et
pas dans une sexualité qui soit purement
mécanique
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de remettre le consentement
au cœur des interactions mais pas
forcément que dans la sexualité au cœur
de des interactions dans la société et
ça peut être aussi sur des actes par
exemple on éduque aussi au consentement
de ce qui pourrait se passer dans une
séance de gynécologie on a tellement eu
l'habitude que nos corps nous nous
appartiennent pas que dans les séances
de consultation gynécologique il y a
très peu de la part des soignants
d'explications sur ce qui va se passer
de demandes de consentement à pratiquer
un acte pénétratif quand même et donc
tout ça voilà nous c'est recentré en
fait le corps l'intégrité du corps
d'avoir une semelle entière où on prend
le temps d'expliquer de former de
montrer le champ des possibles des lieux
où on peut être accueillis où on peut
apprendre où on peut arriver en urgence
etc pour moi c'est c'est hyper rassurant
[Musique]
et d'autres interviews à suivre sur
cette thématique cette semaine dans le 7
8 un peu de sport avec cette incroyable
performance des footballeuses U13 de
trap elles sont revenu hier de Bastia
avec le titre de la made et vous le
voyez le trophée de cette compétition
est avec nous en plateau le plus grand
tournoi de football on le rappelle
amateur en France cette madewi League
les Yvelinois se sont imposés en finale
face à l'Olympique de Marseille au terme
d'une séance de tir au but il y avait eu
0 à 0 à l'issue du temps réglementaire
et cette finale s'est déroulée au stade
Armand Cesari de Bastia on va revenir
sur cette grosse performance avec nos
invités je les ai tout à l'heure il y a
Rodrigue mbezy le coach des U13 féminine
de trap et vous avez été rejoint par la
gardienne Akima Hyères bonsoir également
par la capitaine Nina à midi bonsoir de
cette équipe U13 féminine on va
commencer avec vous d'ailleurs Lina en
tant que capitaine de l'équipe là ça y
est on est deux jours après cette
victoire dans cette madelewiss League
vous avez d'ailleurs inscrit le tir au
but la victoire il me semble si je dis
pas de bêtises comment vous sentez après
cette victoire dans cette compétition
bah il y avait je ressentais de la joie
je ressentais du bonheur et
c'était vraiment quelque chose de
remporter la mode de vie on sait pas
déplacer pour rien et on a gagné contre
une grande équipe quand même l'Olympique
de Marseille et toute l'équipe a fait le
taf il est vraiment je les remercie on a
fait une très grande saison et le taf a
plié hier ou avant-hier avec le trophée
de la modeuse League et racontez-moi
l'émotion que vous avez ressenti au
moment où vous avez inscrit ce tir au
but victorieux mais pour moi c'était de
la joie et je suis parti direct voir nos
supporters qui nous ont supporté tout le
tournoi
et il y a aussi l'héroïne de cette
finale on peut la présenter comme ça
avec nous en plateau Akima elle a gardé
parce que vous avez arrêté de penalty je
pense qu'on les a déjà vu mais on va les
revoir voilà on voit les images de cette
finale peut-être l'un de vos penalties
effectivement voilà l'un des penaltys
stoppé je disais vous en avez stoppé
même deux au cours de cette séance mais
quel qu'est-ce que vous retenez de cette
victoire quel regard vous portez sur sur
votre performance sur la performance
aussi de vos coéquipiers
vous êtes fier vous êtes fier de ce que
vous avez accompli oui je suis très très
fière de d'avoir arrêté les deux buts au
turbu ouais c'est une performance
incroyable ça Rodrigue de stopper deux
tirs au but dans une finale ça fait
basculer le match là il y a eu 00 à lui
suivre du temps réglementaire une
gardienne de but qui arrête deux tirs au
but c'est c'est déterminant pour tout
vous dire bon en fait sur ce type de
rencontre on est obligé de calcul de
jouer avec ses forces et ses faiblesses
donc là je vais fasse une équipe qui
était très très forte et tiquement donc
le plan qui avait été choisi pour la
rencontre c'était bah de jeux sur la
patience en tout cas moi je tiens
remercie mes filles parce qu'elles ont
fait preuve de détermination c'est je
les attendais un certain niveau
sincèrement mais pas ce niveau de
détermination là c'était quoi l'ambiance
avant la finale elles étaient confiantes
où il y avait un petit peu
d'appréhension avant d'affronter l'OM il
y a peut-être d'ailleurs des
supportrices de l'OM au sein de votre
équipe c'est possible aussi oui tout à
fait mais je pense qu'on a fait
attraction alors là je pense que chacun
défendait ses couleurs et en fait la
tendance avant la rencontre c'est que en
fait dans ma dans mon mode de management
tu as été bah je pense
super efficace parce qu'en fait on a eu
le temps de préparer la rencontre c'est
pas comme le samedi matin on arrive à
une heure du coup d'envoi on bricole un
peu là on a eu quand même quasiment 24
heures pour préparer la rencontre donc
on était assez détendu on a appelé des
parents pour aller chercher de la
confiance de la motivation et des champs
payés d'ailleurs au final qui a été
commenté le commentateur a parlé alors
il a utilisé un terme force celui de
braquage réalisé par trappes vous êtes
d'accord avec ça ou c'est quand même un
peu fort comme mot le braquage il y
avait quand même il y avait une place en
finale donc il y a pas eu de braquage
avant quand même non c'est que le
parcours était maîtrisé dès le départ on
savait que dans cette compétition qu'on
était venu chercher quelque chose parce
qu'en fait j'ai une petite histoire qui
est super marrante c'est que à la
madibus Cup donc qui est l'étape
qualificative Lina qui d'habitude fait
pas attention au règlement tout ça c'est
concentré sur règlement et a attendu
dire qu'en fait que la finaliste les
finalistes à des participants à la donc
elle m'avait promis d'y aller donc au
début j'étais un peu sceptique et au
final ils sont allés sauf qu'on a
rencontré une difficulté on a perdu la
finale donc moi je pensais que les
tickets suffisait ça a pas suffi donc
elles se sont consoler c'est chez les
larmes brebis au boulot et on a gagné à
madagas League grâce à ce retour
d'expérience qui est super magnifique
Nicolas tu parlais de taf du travail du
coup fait durant toute la saison c'est
quoi concrètement
on a bossé on a travaillé pour y arriver
aujourd'hui et on a fait le taf on s'est
mis à travailler on a dit c'est pas
grave on a perdu quelque chose mais on
est parti jusqu'au bout et on a réussi à
gagner la prochaine étape
mais c'est la vie des défaites et de
repartir de pouvoir repartir petite
question piège comment tu qualifies le
coachonnerie Rodrigue
le cochon truc c'est un bon coach il
nous donne
les bons choix les bons postes il sait
il sait comment faire il sait son taf et
ça a payé avec un bon coach alors c'est
une victoire qui a fait beaucoup de
Trappes on va voir les images hier de
votre retour dans la vie c'était au
niveau du stade Gilbert Champsec avec
quoi 150 personnes vous me disiez tout à
l'heure audrigue qui était venu pour
vous pour vous accueillir
Akima peut-être qu'est-ce que ça vous a
fait de voir autant de personnes
l'avenir vous acclamer ça monte quand
même que vous avez réalisé une grosse
performance à Bastia
quand j'avais vu qu'il y avait beaucoup
de gens ils étaient très fier parce que
j'ai jamais enfin jamais célébrer un
truc
si enfin une victoire comme ça c'est un
premier souvenir de cette ampleur pour
vous
ce que vous avez ressenti en voyant bah
toutes ces personnes heureuses et
réunies pour vous à votre arrivée à
trappe mais j'ai vu que dans la section
féminine il y avait beaucoup de
personnes qui nous supportaient beaucoup
de personnes derrière nous et on a dû
qu'on allait gagner ça pour le club pour
la section féminine pour ceux qui ne
supportent derrière nous et voilà
une question parce que le sport c'est
alors oui il y a la qualité physique
mais c'est aussi du mental c'est quoi
l'état d'esprit entre vous les filles
est-ce que vous êtes amis vous voyez
aussi à l'extérieur du sport après les
entraînements avant les entraînements
est-ce que vous vous sortez peut-être
vous voyez à l'école peut-être et puis
les mêmes questions pour toi Rodrigue
est-ce que avant tout c'est une bande de
copines qui se sont engagés les jours au
football ensemble et c'est peut-être ça
qui a fait la différence sur le tournoi
tout à fait en fait par rapport à ce
féminine a toujours été constituée comme
ça en fait c'est qu'on a toujours fait
en sorte de d'intégrer des filles pour
créer des collectifs donc on a la chance
qu'on a c'est que burn on a le modèle
chez les garçons
on va pas se mentir qu'on duplique chez
les filles c'est vrai que nous on a une
manière très particulière de voir le
football c'est que on part du principe
que on peut perdre des matchs ça arrive
mais à partir du moment où l'adversaire
est plus fort que nous j'accepte ma
défaite mais si c'est pas le cas on
lâche rien jusqu'au bout alors vous avez
parlé un petit peu tout à l'heure
Rodrigue pour arriver jusqu'à cette
finale remportée face à l'Olympique de
Marseille il y a eu d'abord le parcours
régional et quel était le parcours lors
de la finale du coup quelle équipe vous
avez pu affronter donc on a affronter
pour le premier match nos amis de
Rueil-Malmaison donc pareil français
à quelques secondes de la fin on égalise
donc on fait un partout le deuxième
match contre nos amis de croissante par
une équipe super accrocheuse qui nous
avait vu jouer le premier match donc à
essayer sur mes faiblesses mais bon on
fait 00 et en fait c'est au cours de la
deuxième journée on s'est révélé on
commence par une victoire 3-0 contre le
club de bussiglia le club corse et on
termine sur une victoire trois ans
contre le Sporting Club de Bastia et
puis pour assurer la place de classement
donc on fait 00 contre l'Olympique de
Marseille ça va l'ambiance face au club
corse c'était pas trop chaud face aux
équipes corses qui étaient à domicile il
y avait les supporters qui supportaient
pour eux qu'ils étaient pour eux il y en
a eu beaucoup mais on a on a réussi à
garder la pression on a joué comment on
savait jouer et les supporters pour nous
c'était rien du tout ça faisait pas de
bruit donc déconcentré dans notre match
et c'était pour la qualification
et du coup il y a eu cette victoire on
le rappelle en finale face à l'Olympique
de Marseille vous l'avez vu vécu comment
le tournoi finalement vous étiez un peu
dans la peau de professionnel on peut le
dire dans ce tournoi Hakima oui
et le trophée était remis par Djibril
Cissé vous le connaissiez Djibril Cissé
avant de faire le tournoi
français qui a joué notamment Auxerre et
a été format Auxerre mais pas que
beaucoup de beaucoup de clubs dans sa
carrière ça c'était aussi un honneur
Rodrigue de pouvoir
avoir le trophée qui est remis par
Djibril 6 au-delà du Trophée ce qui est
extraordinaire pour moi en tant que
coach c'est que j'ai reçu un message la
veille de la finale on me demandant ma
compo des fils a très bien que mes
compos sont ultra secrètes voire
confidentielles donc j'ai joué le jeu et
ça a poussé la différence parce qu'en
fait en termes de en termes de prestige
c'est magnifique ce que le match a été
commenté par
saberge de TF1 de TF1 tout à fait ça a
été un honneur aussi de le rencontrer
c'est en fait je remercie Franck le
président de madewi qui est ami les
équipes dans des conditions juste
exceptionnelles pour des amateurs c'est
juste incroyable donc on le remerciera
jamais assez pour cet événement il a su
des événements pour votre équipe donc on
prépare la fête du samedi 17 juin donc
on organise notre premier tournoi
féminin en catégorie U11 et U13 donc on
espère que tout le monde viendra
nombreux pour saluer la performance des
filles parce que attrape notre section
féminine est très très importante et
puis on présentera le trophée à nos amis
supporters en tout cas merci d'être venu
avec ce trophée en plateau voilà je le
remonte de cette madewi grand portée par
les U13 féminines de l'Étoile Sportive
de trappe une victoire en disant en
finale à l'issue de la séance de tir au
but face à l'Olympique de Marseille
bravo à Hakima bravolina bravo Rodrigue
pour cet énorme performance bravo bien
sûr à toutes les joueuses de l'Étoile
Sportive de trap et surtout merci d'être
venu en parlant plateau vous êtes revenu
tout juste hier de cette grosse
performance et de ce gros tournoi je
pense qu'il va rester longtemps dans
votre mémoire merci d'être venu
débriefer tout ça avec nous en plateau
on va ouvrir à présent une page culture
dans le 7 8
[Musique]
les guitares ont vibré ce weekend dans
nos petits villages yvelinois le
festival tracteur blues a fait étape
cette année à breuil-bois Robert et à
Médan pour ça 8ème édition l'objectif
amené la musique directement dans les
zones rurales retour sur l'événement
avec Mathilde Franco et vous Nicolas
dandry
[Musique]
du rock de la folk mais surtout du blues
le festival tracteur blues et de retour
dans la campagne yvelinoise tracteur
blues est né il y a 8 ans avec l'idée
que les petits villages n'avaient pas de
salle de spectacle et l'idée c'était
donc d'amener le spectacle vivant et
pour nous la musique dans les villages
et d'imaginer tout un tout un site en
fait qui pourrait correspondre le temps
d'une soirée à un petit festival en
plein air donc avec une scène qui arrive
avec ce fameux tracteur un village des
artisans un standard restauration des
buvettes et cette année ce sont les
communes de Breuil Bois Robert et Médan
qui ont vu la scène arriver sur la place
du village grâce à un tracteur
on a la chance de l'avoir cette année ça
fait cinq ans qu'on l'attendait breber
donc c'est un village rural qu'on essaye
de faire vivre au maximum avec ce type
d'animation dans notre commune
les artistes présents à mes dents les
élèves du Conservatoire à rayonnement
départemental hotpoz et le groupe blue
[Rires]
fevera convivial quoi c'est ses venait
avec nous c'est venez vous embarquer
venez faire la fête venez danser venez
chanter venez parce que c'est parce que
pour moi c'est la conception que j'ai du
rock c'est la musique que j'aime et
venir faire un festival tracteur blues
ça me paraît complètement logique avec
la musique qu'on fait parce que c'est
effectivement quelque chose du terroir
et pour cette huitième édition le public
est une nouvelle fois conquis je trouve
ça super c'est vraiment vraiment génial
ça anime c'est génial je trouve que ça
permet de rendre la musique accessible à
tout le monde de plus le fait que ce
soit gratuit c'est enfin c'est super
c'est on n'en voit pas tellement et donc
c'est vraiment génial de pouvoir inciter
à ça au niveau des des groupes qui
passent c'est très très bon il y a un
très bon niveau sur les deux jours de
festival 6 groupes se sont succédés au
total l'événement a réuni environ 700
personnes
Nicolas vous avez réalisé les images à
Breuil Bois Robert c'est un peu insolite
de voir un tracteur amené directement la
scène dans un village là pour ce
festival effectivement vendredi matin 8h
un tracteur qui amène la scène sur la
place qui est située juste à côté de la
mairie mais ça a bien fait chanter la
campagne Ibiza je crois que vous avez
bien dansé aussi Grégory effectivement
le lendemain à mes dents très très belle
ambiance en tout cas pour ce festival
directement dans des communes rurales
des Yvelines TV 68 on le rappelle était
partenaire de cet événement alors près
de 300 ans après la commande de Louis
XIV à André Le Nôtre cet événement bien
sûr avec le grand bassin du domaine
national de Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui
est enfin sorti de terre l'inauguration
avait lieu sur place dimanche dernier
avec ses 50 mètres de diamètre il est le
plus grand bassin d'Île-de-France et a
nécessité plus de 18 mois de travaux
Régine raleche on parle justement avec
Benoît Baptiste et mer adjoint de la
commune de Saint-Germain-en-Laye bonjour
monsieur Baptiste
alors justement dimanche 4 juin c'était
l'inauguration du grand bassin au
domaine national de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est un événement
attendu puisque il y a 18 mois à la
première pierre avait été déposée
notamment par l'ancienne Première
ministre ministre de la Culture Rossin
Bachelot alors c'est inauguration
j'imagine que vous en êtes fier quel est
votre sentiment aujourd'hui ah bah oui
absolument parce que vous savez on nous
l'attendant depuis en fait plus de plus
de 18 mois nous l'attendons de plus
presque trois siècles puisque ce grand
bassin a été dessiné par Le Nôtre et
puis au moment où Louis XIV a décidé de
quitter Saint-Germain pour s'installer à
Versailles et bien il n'a plus été
entretenu et donc on attendait depuis
cette époque de pouvoir reconstituer le
grand bassin et donc nous sommes très
heureux que ce grand projet soit enfin
réalisé et que nous ayons pu inaugurer
hier avec un temps magnifique une qui
était très je dirais à la fois
spectaculaire et et familial et puis
beaucoup de monde et une lumière superbe
donc voilà c'est que du bonheur et à
cette inauguration TV 78 a pu y assist
je vous propose de regarder les images
avec plaisir
350 ans il aura fallu plus de 3 siècles
pour que la vision de Lenôtre se réalise
dans le parc du château de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye le bassin de 50
mètres de diamètre le plus grand
d'Île-de-France apporte la touche finale
au grand ensemble imaginé par le
jardinier royal
[Musique]
alors il y a des débats là dessus on
sait qu'il a existé sur les plans on
sait que le nôtre le voulait on pense
qu'il a existé mais il y a sans doute eu
dès le départ des problèmes d'adduction
d'eau on n'a pas réussi à l'alimenter en
eau et évidemment un bassin qui n'a pas
d'eau en plus un bassin aussi important
ça peut pas durer éternellement donc il
a progressivement disparu un bassin
oublié et des jardins disparus au fil du
temps le départ de Louis XIV pour
Versailles avait laissé le temps faire
son ouvrage jusqu'à ce jour de 2020 où
la ville de Saint-Germain et la
Fondation du Patrimoine décide de lancer
une souscription parce que l'État a dit
c'est que on se consacrait nous état à
l'entretien du château mais si les
collectivités territoriales trouvaient
les crédits pour restaurer le grand
bassin on y serait favorable et on
accompagnerait et c'est ce qui s'est
produit et c'est ça qui est merveilleux
coût total plus de 6 millions et demi
d'euros mais la réalisation de ce bassin
qui s'ajoute à deux autres de plus
petites tailles est aussi et avant tout
une prouesse technique un mètre plus bas
seulement se trouve vouloir de la gare
adjacente une contrainte technique
surmontée en près de deux ans pour
permettre de donner enfin au parc sa
perspective finale
[Musique]
pour avoir un point focal dans une
perspective il faut avoir un objet à
regarder et ici l'objet c'est le jet
d'eau et donc ce point focal est placé à
un endroit qui est la convergence de
tous les regards vers l'horizon et
au-delà des aspects esthétiques et
symboliques la finalisation du grand
parterre est aussi l'occasion d'établir
un nouveau trait d'union entre la ville
et les jardins
alors ce bassin qu'est-ce qui va
apporter au domaine national de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye le domaine en fait
c'est le parc du château qui a été conçu
à l'époque dans The Louis XIV part André
Lenôtre et il a voulu vous savez le nom
c'est le spécialiste déjà à la française
et donc dans ce parc de Saint-Germain il
y a la grande terrasse qui fait 2 km 500
et qui est une sorte de belvédère sur le
Bassin parisien sur la défense sur sur
Paris et puis il y a maintenant dans ce
grand bassin qui s'inscrit dans la
perspective des Loges qui est une
perspective donc qui traverse la forêt
et qui va du château juste à la maison
d'éducation de la Légion d'honneur et
puis la Fête des Loges puisque c'est là
que la grande kermesse a lieu tous les
étés donc que c'est un ouvrage qui est
très intéressant sur le plan technique
parce que nous sommes sur les voûtes du
RER donc il a fallu
en fait poser ce bassin sur des
microspieux il y a 50 micro pieux en
acier c'est presque comme si on faisait
un pont en fait en quelque sorte et
ce sera le c'est le plus grand bassin il
fait 50 mètres de diamètre c'est le plus
grand bassin de la région parisienne et
puis la CG2 donc on a lancé les jets
d'eau hier avec un jet d'eau central qui
monte jusqu'à 20 mètres de haut et puis
une série de de G latéraux qui forment
une sorte de de bouquets donc vous savez
les jardins c'est à la fois donc la
nature qui est qui est maîtrisée qui est
organisée et puis c'est l'eau et les
tous les grands châteaux ont par exemple
le grand canal à Versailles etc donc
cette pièce d'eau est un élément
constitutif de la nature qui s'intègre
dans les jardins à la française et c'est
ça que nous avons voulu reconstituer et
alors pour mettre en place ce projet
donc plusieurs personnes plusieurs
collectivités territoriales aussi ont
financé ce projet il est à hauteur de 6
millions d'euros à combien est-ce que la
ville de Saint-Germain-en-Laye a
participé alors effectivement c'est une
mobilisation je dirais à tous les
niveaux des pouvoirs publics puisqu'il y
a l'état en premier lieu qui est
propriétaire du domaine et qui est qui
est chez lui
ensuite la région est intérieure de la
région Île-de-France le département des
Yvelines et puis il y a aussi une part
importante de mécénat privé le groupe
Suez mais aussi à travers la Fondation
du Patrimoine nous avons à peu près 400
donateurs avec des montants qui peuvent
aller de somme très modestes jusqu'à des
montants plus importants et donc
l'ensemble des des dons privés
600000 euros dans 10% du total qui est
un très beau résultat est ce qui montre
que la population de Saint-Germain et
des environs c'est approprié ce projet
et donc la ville a comme elle a le delta
de l'ensemble de ces financements c'est
à peu près un million cinq
et alors on a pu le voir aussi dans les
images il y avait énormément de
personnes à l'inauguration le dimanche 4
juin est-ce que vous avez prévu des
prochaines animations à ce lieu des
choses en fait vous savez ce parc de
Saint-Germain et extrêmement visité
puisque finalement il est juste à la
sortie du RER on compte à peu près un
million de visiteurs par an donc nous
allons régulièrement dans le cas des
animations qui sont faites dans ce parc
et bien proposer des initiatives et il y
a par exemple l'été culturel qui qui va
intervenir dans quelques semaines et
puis ensuite naturellement la journée du
patrimoine enfin bref c'est vraiment un
un lieu que les Saint-Germain noir et
les visiteurs du parc sont déjà
appropriés vous citer une petite
anecdote en tant que mère adjoint j'ai
la le plaisir de célébrer des mariages
et bien l'autre jour les mariés après la
célébration sont allés se faire prendre
en photo devant le grand bassin voilà
c'est déjà un lieu qui est qui devient
familier et marquant d'ailleurs merci
beaucoup Benoît Baptiste d'avoir accepté
notre invitation merci à vous
pour ce grand bassin du domaine national
de Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui a enfin pu
voir le jour je vous le disais un 300
ans après la commande de Louis XIV à
André Le Nôtre on parle à présent de
cinéma dans le 7 8 nous l'avions
rencontré au festival de Cana en 2019 au
tout début de son projet
cinématographique la réalisatrice et
j'ai une assuré qui est originaire de
Chevreuse va proposer pour la première
fois au public une projection de son
film l'âge d'or qui nous plonge dans le
Saint-Tropez des années 1960 la
projection se déroule ce mercredi à
20h30 c'est au cinéma le Champo à Paris
on regarde tout de suite l'interview
express
[Musique]
fin des années 60 dans un petit village
français mais pas n'importe lequel
sûrement le plus célèbre dans le monde
Saint-Tropez deux artistes se
rencontrent et vont faire l'histoire on
peut dire à l'image de la vague hippie
ensemble vivre une histoire d'amour mais
qui va très vite devenir très artistique
on avait projeté de manière tout à fait
privée avec la mairie de Saint-Tropez et
l'office du risque de Saint-Tropez le
film pour que les partenaires et aussi
l'équipe puisque le découvrir en avant
avant première mais là cette fois-ci
c'est vraiment la première française du
film ce mercredi 7 juin au Champeau rue
des Écoles et ça va être je crois
l'aboutissement de beaucoup de choses
mais surtout ça va être je pense je
pense beaucoup au public en fait qui va
enfin pouvoir découvrir ce film mais et
je crois que ça va être le début de
beaucoup de belles rencontres
alors pour l'instant c'est vraiment de
de profiter de mercredi avec le public
pour la première et après prévoir
d'autres dates notamment on commence à
regarder pour les dates pour Lyon mais
aussi bien sûr la distribution en France
plus large et à l'international pour que
l'âge d'or soit accessible au plus grand
nombre on travaille avec un distributeur
américain sur ce sujet et ce sera
formidable après la première avec la
France de pouvoir voir ce film voyager
plus
[Musique]
bientôt la fin du 7 8 avant de se
quitter dernier coup d'oeil aux
prévisions météo de demain
il va faire chaud à nouveau dans les
Yvelines grand soleil dans la matinée
avec des températures proches des 20
degrés 17 degrés sont annoncés par
exemple à Rambouillet l'après-midi le
ciel devrait se voiler thermomètre lui a
qui flirtera autour des 30 degrés 27
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie est très
précisément Versailles et également à
Houdan 28 degrés du côté de Rambouillet
et c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci de votre
fidélité demain nous serons en direct
depuis le prisme à Élancourt à
l'occasion de la soirée d'annonce de la
saison 2023 2024 de la salle de
spectacle la belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]